في سؤال دائما ينتقل علينا او قد مر عليكم
يقول لك جيت فشلت في حياتك جيت حسيت في
مرحله من حياتك انه انت فشلت في ناس كثير
ممكن تقول لك والله ممكن
اتوقع انا ما اعترف بالفشل وفي ناس تقول
لك اصلا مستحيل يكون في فشل فشل ورجعت مره
ثانيه طيب ابص لكم لو سالتكم انتم اي نوع
من الانواع عندي تايب اي وعندي تايب تايب
ايه بكل بساطه شخص عمره ما واجهته ولا اي
مشكله وفجاه واجهات مشكله كبيره طيب
انسان يتعرض لمشاكل كثير في حياته وفجاه
واجهتهم مشكله مره كبيره
بتفكر في السؤال قصدي في الجواب خليه
بعدين هنرجع له بكل بساطه
مرحله من مراحل حياتي قبل عشره سنين
تقريبا كلنا نعرف انه الطلاب والطالبات
اللي يدخلوا علمي ما كان عندهم الا مصارع
اياكم يا هندسه واذا ولد ايش يسوي عنده
فرصه ثالثه ان هو يدخل طيران طبعا الله
سبحانه وتعالى من عليه وحققت امنيه جدي
ودخلت
بدات الرحله الجميله طبيعي
اول ما دخلت الجامعه الحمد لله رجعت كانت
مره عاليه مسك نشاطات في الكليه اللي
اشتغلت فيها قدرت مؤتمرات مسكت انشطه
طلابيه وعندي علميه وما الى ذلك
الكل والجميع كان يعرفني
عدد السنه الاولى السنه الثانيه السنه
الثالثه اشوف كيف الدرجات طبعا جات اخر
السنه
اللاب توب الجوال ماني فاكره كان وقتها
عندي تسعه مواد اتوقع اااه اطول الاقي اف
اشوف كده
ههه
على فكره انا وقتها جبت 58
اتوقع تخفيضات البلاك فرايدي اعلى من
الدرجه الاولى
المهم طبعا وقتها خلاص يعني شعرت بالخوف
الحزن الوحده تملكني احساس الرعب الانكسار
الهزيمه يا ربي نجح اسوي هل هذا معقول طيب
انا كيف ارجع زي ما كنت
ايش اللي بيصير يعني الدنيا تحولت راس على
عقب
اا تملكني احساس كذا يعني التقليل من
الذات جلد الذات انتفاش لا كيف هتقول لامك
كيف هتقول لابوك فين العيله اللي كانت تحس
انك هتطلعي بكتابه
تحولت حياتي الجحيم لسواد
وهذي كذا لازم اوقف اقولها اني دائما
وابدا فديك السنه اللي انا عدتها وكنت
دائما اتمنى انه انا اطلع من الكليه
لهذه الدرجه
لاني ما كنت ابغى اصحى على شان اواجه نفس
الاحاسيس نفس المشاعر الناتجه تقول عني هل
من جد انا كده حياتي انتهت وهي لسه ما
بتلد
كان لازم اعدي عديت السنه طلعت السنه اللي
بعدها
عديت السنه تخطيت المرحله هذه لكن انا ما
لي خطيت الاحساس
بالانكسار والهزيمه وكيف دفعه راحت طب
وانا ايش اسوي
لدرجه انه لما كانت عندي مشكله مع الدرجات
والارقام لدرجه انه لما كانت تنزل الدرج
ايش كنت تسوي
درجاتي طبعا يعني انا عندي فوق رعب لا
يمكن كنت السن الكليه تنزل الاسماء حق
الناس اللي عايدين المواد
على فكره
[ضحك]
ااا الين ما مرحله كده في حياتي للان طبعا
لو تسالوني ليش سويت زي كذا راح اقول لكم
والله ما اعرف
صيف 2019 كذا صفه 2019 انا انسان طفشانه
لحالي والصراحه يعني اللي خلاني اني انا
يعني ابادر هذه المبادره انه انا ما سافرت
لانه ما كنت باسافر كيف اسافر وانا راسي
ايش اقول للناس ايش البشير اللي انا فيها
اااه حضرت احضر كورسات في احد المستشفيات
الخاصه بجده كان همم على الطب الباطني
طبعا كان مختلف همم
المدن هنا في المملكه طبعا انا عارفه ليش
حاضر الكورس بس قالوا لي بتخليني ادخل
يعني ما نستفيد شيء
طبعا كل الناس كانوا يجلسوا قدام كده
ويبغى يسمع المحاضرات
ويبغى يعني يستفيدوا طب باطني وكده على
فكره تجلس اجلس وراء كان في احد التكاتره
دائما يرجعني كذا يجيبهن من وراء يقول لي
تعالي قدام كل يوم على نفس المنوال لمده
ثلاثه اسابيع وايه رايك كذا يجيبني من
وراء يحطني قدامي جيب من وراء طفشت
الرجاله خلاص يعني وصلت معي انت جايه
اليوم من الايام
حدث ما لم يكن توقعه جاء عندي
في الحياه
وبحكم تجارب ممكن الكلمه اللي قال لي هي
هذه قالها لكل الطلاب ولا لكل الناس اللي
بيقابلهم يعني هو ما كان يعني لي انا فقط
يا بنتي طيب ترى عادي ترى عادي انه احنا
نمر بمشاكل وترى عادي انه احنا تصير لنا
عقبات في حياتنا ترى الشعور اللي انت
بتحسيه
ترى جدا طبيعي لكن
الجماليه في الموضوع والحلو في الموضوع
انه نحن كيف راح نتخطى هذه المشكله طبعا
هو قال لي هذا الكلام ممكن لم يلقي بال
ايش ممكن ياثر علي هذا الكلام هذيك الكلمه
في هذيك اللحظه كانوا واقعها على قلب زي
السحر صدمتني صدمتني انت شلتني من القاع
الى السطح
من الظلام الى النور
غيرت مجرى حياتي بكل بساطه
ايش نستفيد من هذا الموضوع انه الانسان
لازم ان هو يصادف بيئه جديده ناس جديده
مجتمع جديد لا تدري من ممكن تقابل مين
ممكن يعطيك نصيحه مين ممكن تشوف منه حركه
مين ممكن تنحجب بشخصيه توت تغير مجرى
حياتك من لا شيء الى شيء
اه
طبعا
كملت الحمد لله همم الكورس يعني كان جميل
جدا استفدت
وحدت الايام لكن انا بسالكم سؤال
ايش الفرق ما بين الاله والانسان ايش
الفرق
احساس
مشاعر وعي ادراك عقل
كل هذه الاشياء في مقوله جميله احد رجال
الاعمال في المملكه العربيه السعوديه قبل
الوزير السابق
للصحه الدكتور توفيق الربيع قال له بالله
هي دكتور كيف تخطيت رائحتك باقل الاضرار
كيف قدرنا ننجاح والعالم السعوديه كل كلمه
واحده كلمه واحده قال له كن انسان لا اكثر
ولا اقل كل انسان
تختلف المهن تختلف الوظائف لازم ولابد ان
تكون الطبيب الانسان
المعلمه الانسان
الاداري الانسان
الكاتب الانسان فعندما تفقد الانسان في
العقيمتها للوظيفه ولا للمهنه
دائما وابدا
لما تيجي تكلم احد
تنصح احد حط نفسك مكان الشخص حترضى على
نفسك دائما يوظف الانسان الذي بداخلك وليس
الاعلى دائما يصادف مواقف يقول لك والله
يكون عندك مشكله كذا كبيره ما حد
يحل المشكله وتروح عند الناس تقول لك
والله حس فيا والله فهمني كده
لانه فقدنا الانسانيه في المهن الشهاده
الوظيفه المراتب كلها لا تنسيك انه في
انسان بداخلك لازم ترجع لهذا الانسان في
كل خطوه تخطيها
شكرا
طبعا من هنا الحمد لله بدات سلسله
التطورين نجاحاتي نشرت اكثر من خمسه ابحاث
في مجلات معروفه شاركت في اكثر من ثمانيه
مؤتمرات
بادرت في اكثر من 10 حملات تطوعيه
قدرت اكثر من الحمد لله هينا بدات نفس
الشيء
مسيرته في السوشيال ميديا اه على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي انستغرام خلال ممكن
قدرت اكثر من 50 حوار مع 50 طيف او اكثر
منهم اطباء وغير اطباء ولله الحمد حصل لك
اعلى نسبه مشاهده في ذلك الحين بما يقارب
مجموعها كان 120,000 مشاهد
استضافت في كثير من البرامج التلفزيونيه
من الاذاعات
طلعت في الجرايد محليه الحمد لله
طبعا كثير تسمعوا وتطبي يعني هي جايه
تحكمين غلط بس نخلي نشرح لكم هي الفكره
انه انا اكتفيت انا ما اكتفيت كل هذه
الاشياء اللي سمعتوها ما هي الا رحله انا
استمتع بالرحله كل هذا الانجازات ما هي
الا الكرزه اللي فوق الكيكه
[تصفيق]
دائما وابدا هتواجهنا عقبات وحتواجهنا
مشاكل في حياتنا لكن تذكر ان تصل متاخرا
خيرا من ان لا تصل
ايش القفز اللي صارت في حياتي ايش اللي
تغير في حياتي هي اشياء بسيطه
تالمت
تالمت تعلمت التزمت
في ناس تتالم تتعلم لكن ما تلتزم وترجع لي
خاطر البدايه والحمد لله بعدها تغيرت
ورضيت
فشلت نعم فشلت
اثر في الفشل نعم
لكن احيانا كثير الفشل
نعمه وليس نقمه كثير من الناس يقولوا انه
والله انا فشلت دائما وابدا تذكر انه نجاح
الحقيقي هو عدد المرات التي تستعيد فيها
توازنك من الفشل فتذكر ان بدايه الصيف ايش
الشتاء
وبدايه النور الظلام وبدايه الضغوطات
الراحه
فمن قوه الفشل تنبعث الطاقه صح ولا لا
جميل طيب
السؤال اللي قلت لكم انتم تايب ايه ولا بي
واحد مشكلات واحد مو مشكله تفتكروه صح بكل
بساطه انا انسانه تايب مي تايب نفسي
انسانه تعرضت لمشكله كبيره
قابلت شخص كان معها الطبيب الانسان حس
فيها نصحها تغيرت مجرى حياتها
دائما وابدا اذا تبغى الناس تساعدك تساعد
الناس واذا تبغى الناس تدعي لك ادعي للناس
واذا تبى الناس تحس فيك تحس في الناس
الخير عباره عن دائره تلف تلف تلف تلف
وترجع لك لانه الجزاء دائما من جنس العمل
بالمناسبه شايفين هذاك الكورنر اللي هناك
كلكم شوفوا هذاك الزاويه اللي احنا هناك
هذيك الزاويه اللي هناك
هذيك الزاويه بكل بساطه قبل سته سنين كانت
الزاويه اللي قلبت حياتي رقص على عقب
الزاويه اللي اختبرت فيها الماده وعدتها
وها انا اليوم في نفس المكان من زاويه
اخرى على مسرح من كليه البترجي
لاول مره اشارككم قصتي
رسالتي لكم انت من تحدد زاويه حياتك حتى
ترى نجاحك شكرا لكم
[تصفيق]